Uh,
I'm Karen Sunburg.
I'm the diversity lead for tech.
Um,
and I probably wouldn't normally be the person introducing this session,
but,
um,
I used to work for Sylvia at the center for talent innovation and I joined
Google last year,
so it was very exciting to welcome her back here today to talk about executive
presence,
which was a piece of research that started happening when I was still at the
center and was really transformative for me and for others as we talk to
companies about thinking about how,
you know,
what is leadership,
what does it,
what are the leadership archetypes and,
um,
and how do,
how do you become an effective communicator?
And you know,
what does it mean to have gravitas and all these big pieces that we don't often
think about.
Um,
but that are crucially important in addition to doing our work.
also how we come across and how we relate our messages.
So I'm excited to welcome Sylvia here today.
Um,
one thing that I learned about executive,
why I learned a lot of things about executive presence from Sylvia,
but,
um,
one was that you should always have one fun piece of,
you know,
maybe in your appearance,
some fun piece of clothing.
That was always something that I noticed that she did and used very effectively
actually.
And so in honor of her today,
I wore leopard shoes because she always had leopard and she,
I think she has a bag that's leopard.
So I'm right on target today.
Um,
but I wore like Google safe leopard,
you know,
like not too much.
Um,
but I'm very excited to welcome Sylvia here to talk about her new book on
executive presence,
which was voted the best book of the month by Amazon this month.
So pretty awesome.
Um,
and so without further ado,
Sylvia,
welcome.
Okay.
So it is fabulous to connect with Karen.
She has much more important things to do this morning,
but we already did a little catch up over breakfast,
so that was fabulous.
I want to begin with a story,
uh,
because this,
topic,
uh,
goes to the core of some of my failure and some of the challenges I had early in
my life.
I grew up in the coal mining area of south Wales.
Uh,
this is a very depressed piece,
sub to UK.
The unemployment rate in my valley when I was growing up was 38%,
uh,
because the coal industry was closing down.
And you know,
I did come from a hard scrabble hardscrabble family and partly because of the
woman's movement,
partly because they were trying to get our folks on the wrong side of the tracks
to made universities.
I did end up at Cambridge when I was 18 and I was broke.
I did pass a lot of exams,
but I spoke English with this thick working class while Jackson,
which was the kiss of death and polite English society,
which is very,
um,
you know,
very class conscious.
I also did not use gramma,
uh,
you know,
kind of correctly.
I grew up with a lot of bad habits because you know,
this was on a reading household.
And I remember knowing when I was 18 that no matter how great I was at my work,
every time I open my mouth,
I let myself down.
It was also true that Cambridge was only 7% female at the time.
So there was enough going on in terms of the gender barriers to make me feel it.
At least I had to fix the way I talk if I was going to get anywhere.
So I spent two years listening to the BBC will service
practicing those modulated tones and also fixing my grandma.
And it did make me much more accessible,
much more successful,
much more able to actually communicate my thoughts.
Now looking back on it,
there was a lot of bias going on in that story,
right?
What's wrong with regional accent?
Okay.
Uh,
what's wrong with looking clause accidents?
Now I didn't need to fix my grandma.
That was a good IPO.
Right?
You do want to use the language that is your main vehicle.
Well,
okay,
but back then,
because Kloss was such an issue,
I also really had to change the way I spoke.
So,
I mean,
this business of how you communicate there is this tension between authenticity
and conformity.
And I think all of our corporate cultures present us with some of these
challenges.
What works,
what gets you over the next hurdle,
but what is tutor yourself?
So let's look at this data.
We've got some amazing data on what is going on in corporate America right now.
Uh,
we looked at 14 sectors,
including the tech sector,
and I will talk some about the specificities of the silicon valley challenge.
So first off,
uh,
I founded the task force on talent innovations some 10 years ago.
Google has been a leader in this group for the last six years.
Uh,
so I have been,
uh,
very much involved in your talent journey here.
In terms of this study.
We have collected incredible data around what allows you to be seen as having
potential as being leadership material,
uh,
as being ready for the next big thing.
Right?
And one thing I want to emphasize here is executive presence.
It's really not about performance.
It's not about whether you really do deliver the goods,
hit the numbers,
you know,
really no.
You'll craft and have the skills.
It's about what you signal about your preparedness for the next big chats
we find right across sector that there are three main pillars,
the executive presence,
which would lead us look for,
I didn't this data,
we went out to hundreds of representative leaders,
uh,
across the private sector.
We also did a ton of focus groups and interviews.
So this really reflects a lot of data collection in terms of what is important
in the eyes of your boss.
So these are the three dimensions that think rabbit tests.
Wow.
That is a biggie.
What we think of that would,
what comes to mind,
I mean,
what do you associate with the word?
Grab a tess
poss confidence
happed in terms of being seen as a intellectual heavyweight.
I mean,
how would you signal that?
Right.
Credibility,
eloquence.
Remember we're talking about communication a little separately here,
but are you think that that is part of the grab a task piece?
It impact very good work.
So we have a bunch of words right that seem to describe it,
but we probably don't know what is most important,
right?
So let's take a look at what the data is telling us,
realizing that there is some intermingling of these things.
For instance,
you can have the most amazing haft
okay?
But if you can't be compelling in how you talk about it,
it remains locked up,
becomes a wealth of kept secret,
right?
So obviously these things are interlinked.
Okay?
So what we find in the data is the gravity tass Willie right across the spectrum
here is seen as the most important piece signal signaling to the world that you
know your stuff cold,
but your five questions deep on your domain of expertise that is at your
fingertips,
right?
There is a very interesting,
uh,
picture emerging here across ethnicity.
And basically what senior leaders at telling us in this survey is what they're
looking for in terms of their team.
That middle level managers,
they're high potential younger folks,
et Cetera.
As we can see whether you're Caucasian or Asian or female or male,
there's tremendous uniformity in terms of the rough proportions,
you know,
grab a test is the biggie.
Communication skills is the second piece that is important and then the
appearance piece seems to be quite small.
There are interesting differences here.
For instance,
for African American leaders,
they are particularly looking for a test and they say,
look,
we know that we struggled with this ourselves.
There is the specter of affirmative action.
They say it's as though we've got a real audition for our jobs all the time
because perhaps way back we got an unfair chance
and in our interviews we found that our gravitas seem to be a potentially big
hurdle for African American.
Want to be leaders
for Asian individuals,
communication is often somewhat more difficult.
Did you come from a B Spec fill deferential culture,
right?
And you value consensus.
How'd you get to be forceful enough in an American centric corporation?
And again,
bias very infused in this data.
But the main messages here is that there's tremendous agreement in terms of what
matters.
So moving on,
let's look at the top picks.
We presented our leaders with about 50 traits.
These are the top six
and again,
amazing agreement,
female and male leaders really picking a very similar list.
Top of the list there is this confidence pies.
Quite a bullet.
See Grace under fire.
Someone who can keep that cool and credibility and depression tremendously.
Admire
that.
Would you say that translated in the tech sector?
Is that something that is important?
I see some nods.
Many people told us in fast based industries or industries where business models
are changing,
this is particularly valued.
Okay.
Interestingly,
charisma is number six.
Write it a little down the list.
People are suspect are big personalities these days.
They prefer the,
the con confidence.
Okay,
now,
but to decisiveness showing teeth.
Now when we look at our middle level employees,
we find that women have a problem with this.
That being tough,
being really forceful can be hard for a female because she seen oftentimes as a
little unlikeable the B would gets rolled up quite a bit.
So there's tough showing.
TC is actually easier for men than for women.
And again,
it reflects,
uh,
the dominant culture,
the mainstream leaders.
You know,
there's bias here.
This is how it's been done by the dominant group.
Right?
So I need reaction here.
Is it harder?
Do you feel for a woman to be super strong minded,
uh,
and remain are someone who is admired?
You know,
two weeks ago,
Jill Abramson,
Bush shot down as the executive editor of the New York Times.
Why?
Well,
we probably read the press.
She was seen as pushy.
She was seen as abrasive.
She was seen as lacking charm.
She did knock a sufficiently mate nice to her,
particularly senior male colleagues.
She was a fabulous leader.
No one was criticizing her track record or what she'd done in China.
So it is tough,
particularly in somewhat traditional fields baps but if you look at number four,
it's fascinating.
Emotional intelligence.
This is where we find women really do amazingly well.
There is more of an empathy factor that women are able to get out there at work.
And these days,
why is emotional intelligence newly prize?
And usually on this list,
a lot of leaders said,
look,
it's shooting up the charts didn't,
he didn't use to be on the list.
But now it is.
So why is emotional intelligence important?
If you want to be a leader,
right?
And your team is probably diverse,
So sitting in someone else's shoes,
pretty important and valuing difference.
Pretty important.
The other thing we find is that customers and clients can be very diverse.
They can be big global these days don't we all look and global teams.
So they'll,
empathy builds trust
and you can't just be the top down command and control guy anymore.
I'm happy at work.
So in a way,
this is nicely mixed up.
You know,
some of these prize attributes are more natural or perhaps more instinctual for
men are this for women.
We don't know whether that's socialization or really how we're born,
but it's devil as true.
And uh,
the thing that we find in the final pick here,
vision yes,
is prized,
but it measured vision.
One that can put data around one that you have a lot of evidence around the
charisma bit,
which is just,
you know,
turning people on about your path forward does not work so well anymore.
So moving on,
we asked leaders,
who is that icon who brought off grab a tests better than anyone else?
Yeah,
top choice.
What's Mandela?
We explored why he was so admired.
He was thought to be the complete package,
the extraordinary integrity force and vision nop,
his journey,
the ways in which he had and leadership,
but also his amazing ability to understand the power of symbolism
and to connect on a very human level.
This particular episode,
uh,
what you probably a,
well maybe you're all too young to remember this,
but he was newly president of South Africa.
The rugby team,
the springboks had just won the world championship.
Uh,
the springboks team,
we're recalcitrance Afrikaans 100% of the team,
well,
white South Africans from the,
uh,
Afrikaans group,
which was the group that had actually designed and fought for a pocket.
So this was the group that Nelson Mandela had spent 23 years in jail.
Poor.
But they won.
South Africa was the champion.
So Mandela leaps out of the stand.
Dawn's the Springbok Jersey.
I'm hugs the captain,
this flash round the world,
this image,
because what did show was this new president was really about reconciliation and
healing
and this set right?
This man had the most amazing emotional intelligence as well as half
as well as integrity.
Okay,
Jamie diamond's on this.
This,
do you know,
Steve Jobs is kind of on this list,
although he was thought to be a little suspect because of just the eccentricity
of his personality.
But it's an interesting,
yes.
Do you know what leaders choose as their icons?
The other thing we find out from grabbing task is how does it go badly bar?
How'd you cut yourself off at the knees so that no matter how good you're out of
here,
so know sexual impropriety seems to be a,
uh,
a way in which men,
you know,
hit the skids.
Uh,
think of Petraeus.
Spitzer,
Robina,
you know,
Clinton was impeached after all.
Um,
you know,
there is a way in which a senior man,
I really do know that this is a way of,
uh,
getting,
written out,
but other,
uh,
behaviors that get you in trouble is a lying,
covering up a,
the bully piece,
you know,
does not get you anywhere these days and tends to again,
get you crossed off the list and an off color or racially insensitive set of
remarks.
We'll do the same.
Mitt Romney famously was seen as someone who had a tin ear,
was clueless about how most people lived.
He was in this bubble.
It was such a privilege man.
He,
uh,
really didn't know how the world work,
so he could talk about having binders full of women or he could tell the world
that,
you know,
47% of the population were losers because they were on benefits and he included,
um,
uh,
veterans and the disabled in terms of the losers on his list.
Uh,
in other words,
the reason he lost that election was that he was so profoundly insensitive as to
how other people lived or what their challenges were out of course,
is in the middle of his scandal right now.
He's seen as a bully.
He's seen as someone who trying to cover up.
And again,
you know,
you couldn't see the blunders as being,
uh,
elements which will probably be a ensure that he does not run for president next
time rock.
So he has some tactics.
How do deal
with some of these issues that are problematic for you?
For instance,
if you're a woman,
how do you make your force?
You are very strong opinions.
Your track record really saying,
we did lots of interviews for this research and you know,
maybe you sugar coat your strength with some humor or you when you have a
massively important,
a new campaign that you totally believe it,
you also go on some kind of charm offensive to make sure that people find it
palatable.
Maybe you do none of the above because you know your non negotiables and there's
no way in which you want to bend your demeanor
or your approach to just please
the culture you're in.
So I think we all face tension here.
Maybe we all willing to bend at the margins if one is a,
uh,
a man who has lived in a pretty straight arrow environment,
the way you bend at the ages,
I really listening for bias in your environment and forcing yourself to
understand the other,
right?
So again,
you know,
we find that the tension between authenticity and conformity between standing in
and standing out,
uh,
you know,
is really permeates these things.
But by and large,
women do need to understand that making this dress somehow work for them
is a challenge in a lot of organizational culture and for men figuring out how
to show empathy.
Yeah.
Again,
a commonplace challenge in their teamwork.
The other thing I wanted to say is,
uh,
if fuel reputation and the wood at the water cooler precedes you,
how would you signal
your reputation,
your statue,
in ways that aren't annoying?
You know,
you're in a company,
I guess,
which doesn't have a whole lot of titles,
right?
So sometimes it's a little hard to show your experience.
I show you're legally credentials.
So any ideas here in terms of how to again,
just signal that gravitas somehow established from the get go in a meeting that
you know what you're talking about,
that you have,
uh,
the chops.
Is that an issue at Google?
It is in a lot of young,
you know,
highly geared companies,
few are hired in a,
there's this wonderful assumption that of course you're exceptional.
You're still faced with how do you stand out at Google?
How do you progress?
How do you end up by being tapped on the shoulder for?
It's a major opportunity because we know that they're given,
not not to everyone,
but to those who are seen as ready.
Uh,
so I,
I think,
you know,
this is true of all organizations,
but I thought that was very well expressed.
Thank you.
So let's move on and take a look at a communication
because in some ways,
this is the way in
we find this is oftentimes the icebreaker.
So the top pick and it's very contemporary,
the ability to have kind of this mini Ted talk,
that concise,
compelling value add huge.
Um,
what we find is that leaders particularly price this,
if you couldn't do it seemingly extemporaneously,
it's the kiss of death to rely on notes.
Oh,
too many slides you got to win,
which goes to your point.
This is very hard to bring off.
Not only is it valued in a very fast moving,
um,
incredibly talented cultures like a Google,
but this is true,
you know,
in media on,
on Wall Street.
Uh,
you know,
uh,
at Walmart,
I mean,
this is a demand of the modern workplace.
Attention spans are short,
okay.
To find your voice,
to make it be heard.
The concise,
compelling thing is a must.
Okay.
On,
it's not easy.
And again,
my own story,
I had some pretty terrible habits 12 years ago.
I just spent a bunch of years in academia being a professor,
a very boring professor,
I think.
But,
uh,
I was doing intermediate macro theory is my main thing,
right?
So hard to make that too lightly.
But he was,
he admired style in my department.
You delivered information in 15 minute chunks.
You known people with Abbott turns right and,
and very complex proofs.
Try that out on a book tour.
I was a disaster.
I couldn't do anything without my notes.
So I made myself walk ship.
It's particularly bad interview I did on Charlie rose,
which was particularly galling because it was a big chance to get my message out
and I was terrible.
I was just yawn inducing and I really was a,
with my three by five cards,
you know,
I could not let go of the notes and I force myself to learn what was going wrong
and did I practice practice like crazy.
And before I went to any meeting or made any speech I bang did into my brain.
So I knew the AUC of what I was going to say.
And I knew three different Bush.
Okay.
Just in case the conversation went in a different direction or someone said what
I was about to say and I learned to tell stories,
not long story.
So it can be low.
Well,
it's dark could be luck,
but that
is how you get your confidence.
This is why you know communication is often the way to build the gravity.
Last piece that we were talking about earlier
because it establishes your credibility.
I didn't insure us
that you'll hurt.
Okay,
so how do you move that into the ability to command a space?
A room was the team room or an audience and that is the linked one,
which is at the top of the list here.
This requires a bunch of other things which are actually the surround sound.
It's positive.
How do you sit at a table,
how do you stand in a space?
Some of it is just he knows trading that backbone
and looking competent,
paying attention.
The other piece of it is to let go of that which is between you and your
audience.
Podiums spectacles and again notes.
Get rid of the
and devices,
eye contact,
eye contact.
So we find that,
you know,
we're rolling out a whole bunch of high touch workshops up like this around eep.
This is where one can be transformative
really rather easily.
Any comments in terms of this culture,
what works here
or what is problematic here?
Yeah.
So,
but if you have in your mind,
uh,
a playbook arb,
exactly what you can say,
uh,
several versions of it,
which,
you know,
we'll grab,
it's easier to do that or manipulation of that general conversation together.
So is this a brilliant example of having your emotional intelligence connect
with your communication skills?
Because you know that the leaders need to take ownership of this idea.
You've got to prod them along,
you've got to become indispensable and you've suddenly got to be value add,
right?
But this can be transformative of ones.
How you see,
right?
Um,
are your own
confidence.
Okay.
So moving on,
uh,
what was the top pick here?
Interestingly,
a woman,
um,
Sheryl off course,
we all know,
not only is she seeing him someone of enormous credibility,
but her communication skills,
right?
She did do that Ted talk,
One of the most,
I think it was the most watched ted talk that particular year because she has
this ability
of delivering a clear message and then revealing some of our own vulnerability.
So you can relate to her.
She would be obnoxious if she did not do that because you know,
this is a person who's had a golden path.
Okay,
how do we relate to someone like that?
But she tells us,
you know,
that she put on 60 pounds with that first child.
And you know,
some of her struggles,
I mean,
you can reveal any part of you.
It doesn't have to obviously be family.
You probably shouldn't overshare.
But this is part of embassy
sharing our roots,
you know,
sharing a little piece of failure
and it makes her someone that people want to hear.
And this other thing about the blunders,
because again,
we did look at the blunders.
Are we see again,
bias all over these blunders.
The interesting thing about bias is that executive presence is oftentimes the
place where you see bias revealed
because you're talking about a leadership archetype,
right?
That crying take right?
Turns out men can cry.
Women cannot in the workplace,
think of,
um,
Obama's speech around Trayvon Martin.
He led a few tears
out of his eyes.
We liked him for that.
It showed that this really distant man had hot
and connected to the tragedy of this young person's life.
But when women cry in public,
they're seen as just way too emotional,
who can deal with them,
kind of saying it takes us down and our statue.
So if we look at this lists,
we know that we want a world where there isn't so much bias,
uh,
such a,
you know,
a gendered for instance,
take on what leadership needs to look like.
But this is what's happening this week,
next week,
last week.
This is how people are judged because this is data in terms of what leaders
right now find does not work.
One day,
which I find interesting.
The number one blunder is constant device checking.
Leaders find that profoundly discourteous,
um,
profoundly undermining up a more junior person's gravitas that they are not able
to pay full attention.
So what is the deal at Google?
Because you know,
I think
high silicon valley,
you know,
devices must be so omnipresent.
Um,
but is there a kind of unwritten etiquette here in terms of what happens in key
meetings?
What about iPhones?
I think he get someone who's holding this or maybe it's not an iPhone,
maybe it's
an android.
So tell me what the,
the,
uh,
behavior,
you know,
the dominant behaviors,
but if it gets in the way of you making eye contact with your boss and weighing
in with your power source and doing the clever stuff of linking your emotional
sense of who is really needing to buy in,
in this meeting to my idea and how do I demonstrate my,
uh,
indispensability to this project going forward?
It truly does get it away.
No,
no,
no.
I know,
I'm not saying you personally don't feel it as an attack.
You see what,
what leaders say,
no matter what the technology,
no matter what the value add of,
you know,
being able to complete your sense of some link or whatever the most important
activity,
the main,
uh,
goal of meeting is
to leave it.
Having impressed,
having pushed the ball forward and having a newly central role
and whatever was decided.
So,
I mean I do feel,
I mean,
uh,
I have five kids,
so I have,
I am in touch with,
I mean I don't tend to use devices that much because of my age.
Right.
You know,
it's not a habit I have,
uh,
developed.
Uh,
but I do feel that there is a way in which we can undermine ourselves.
And one thing that is valued above all other things by senior leaders is eye
contact and having the full attention of a younger person.
They bet here.
Okay.
So some more or less humorous examples of what people feel,
uh,
has gone wrong in terms of public displays of this.
Tim Geitner famously cannot make eye contact.
He always accused of looking Naca,
frightened teenager because he deflects,
um,
eye contact.
He almost cannot do it tremendously undermined his credibility
and the forcefulness assertiveness of statements coming from women of color
really on display.
I think with Indra Nucci she gave a very famous speech or not long ago at the
Columbia business school where she took on American,
our arrogance in the world.
She was coming from a very secure place.
Uh,
she was born and brought up in India.
She's been,
you know,
very successful global executives and she is CEO of Pepsi.
But because she's a woman of color,
she got trashed by the press,
which I totally buy white guy reporters who saw her as out of line the
criticizing a country that she had done so well.
So,
you know,
again,
you know that the degree of forcefulness,
the degree of edginess you can show as a woman of color,
really constrained by bias,
by the stereotypes and the archetypes of leadership.
Okay?
So we all know this,
that 80% meet you first time online and you better make sure that you're very
happy with your linkedin,
you know,
manifestations and that you are showing up online in ways that you're proud of.
This is where colleagues and bosses,
where folks who are perhaps interviewing you for an opportunity will really
first meet you.
And I'm sure you all know that very profoundly here.
So I view tactics first,
I lose the prompts,
get rid of the security blankets.
We find that women use,
uh,
about one third more PowerPoint sides of men
because women oftentimes feel that they have to show that they're super well
prepared,
that they really did do all our homework.
Oftentimes they feel that there are very few of them around the table,
particularly a more senior levels.
So they have to show how much work they put into this presentation.
But what it does,
it undermines them because you do above all the to show you can wing it that,
you know,
you stopped cold,
I contact
lower your voice.
This is interesting.
Voices go up under pressure and a stretch
keeping
obvious control,
not speeding up,
not lifting your voice.
Very important in terms of being heard.
We've been using some opera coaches in the workshops we are doing around Erp and
it's fascinating how much you can manipulate your voice.
So as your herd,
and again,
it's got nothing to do with accident.
Most opera singers,
you know,
don't speak any other languages very well at they sing it.
It's all about tone and projection.
Yeah.
And the last one you silence as a weapon.
It's probably a little hard to do at Google because you're describing a very
crowded meeting,
um,
culture where people are
fighting for space,
right?
But in some cultures and on Wall Street is a very good example.
I did an amazing interview with Sally Korczak,
who was head of Merrill Lynch for many years.
She said that as a southern woman,
she was brought up to fill all space with words,
Chitty chat,
because a nice girl was supposed to make everyone else feel comfortable and
silence was awkward.
So she made it her business to Philip all space.
She was totally discounted,
almost three because chitter chatter in southern women,
you know,
don't make much impact.
So what she learned to do was become much more economical.
And what she said,
and she was an audacious,
I mean this was a woman who did not take prisoners in terms of her viewpoints,
okay?
But she learned to surround her very important thoughts with silence
to deliberately make people feel awkward so that they actually listened.
So there's all kinds of tools,
but it's,
it's a performance,
you know,
this is,
this is something that we can all manipulate and it in a way,
this isn't bias.
This is how
you get your boys to camp,
which is why I see the communication thing as the way in,
ah,
too many of the,
uh,
demands of growing competence and credibility.
Okay.
So into appearance,
this is the least important is about 7% of what our leaders say as important.
Okay.
Very good news here.
Grouping and Polish and being appropriate.
Okay.
So much more important than you know,
the sheer size of your body or the texture of your hair or you know,
uh,
exactly what's happening to the in style that you choose to wear.
So what is grooming and Polish?
You know,
we find again in the data that are seemingly casual cultures can be actually a
potter figure out then formal cultures and there are weird trip wires.
For instance,
you know,
remember the IPO of Facebook or the Hoodie Schlubby nerdy people and then they
were Sheryl Sandberg looking quite formal because it's hard to do the hoodie
thing.
And look leaderly if you're a woman,
it's pretty easy to look like a graduate student or someone's assistant,
you know.
In other words,
it is surprisingly tough to negotiate casual cultures and somehow crack it
because there are admired styles even though that would seem to be few rules.
Uh,
one thing that I experienced last summer is,
um,
I was invited to the advertising,
celebration in a can where they give the awards in the industry.
It's called the Cannes lions awards.
And uh,
it's a little like 1963 and that only 3% of the creative directors,
uh,
in the top 50 advertising companies are female.
This is largely a male crowd.
Uh,
it's the rockstars,
you know,
giving each other awards and it's profoundly mail.
So you walk in and you try and figure out what the lockets and it hits you
between the eyes.
There was almost a uniform four day old stubble within,
I mean,
they didn't have a whole lot of hair on their heads,
so they were trying to look very natural,
I think.
And then there were the bespoke shorts.
Okay.
The incredibly expensive watches and flip flops.
That was it.
The few women in the room did not want know what to do.
I mean that they couldn't quite do the stubble saying that what I'm done a much
good.
Right.
And you know,
the shoe thing is hard
because mostly,
mostly the [inaudible].
These would be the net 50 say went the pinnacle of their careers.
Most women don't look that great short 50 well either.
So,
you know,
I guess what I'm trying to say is that there was a code in this room,
but it was a tough one.
I really tough one.
So you know,
again,
what we say is find yourself,
you know,
some role models.
Find what works,
you know,
in your micro climate.
Because I imagined that tech and sales and HR have different demands even at
Google.
Okay?
Because you got to get rid of this.
I mean,
it's not very important,
but it's good not to have this get in your way.
Because the thing about appearance is the first filter,
right?
If you get it profoundly wrong and turn up looking like,
you know,
Hillary Clinton in your pants suits it can,
it would not do you much good.
So it's not that in the end it's important,
but it is surprisingly tricky.
So,
um,
again,
admired folks in terms of the well put together piece.
Uh,
Christine Lagarde thought to be the very elegant,
you know,
uh,
executive woman.
It's great that she's allowed to have white hair.
And then of course,
cancer is hugely admired for his style.
And you know,
uh,
we find that the other thing that was a big tip from this work is that looking
as though your toned and fit is very important.
It's actually much more important than say,
being physically,
uh,
attractive in some,
you know,
chocolate box way.
You've got to look as though you have some resilience these days.
You know,
jobs are demanding to,
to show that you actually work out and you can,
you know,
deal with the travel and deal with the long work weeks.
Uh,
you are signaling vigor and resilience.
Yes.
No,
no.
It's interesting.
It's not,
we tested that,
uh,
and it was particularly important for African American talent that we test that,
we are very forgiving.
I mean within some limit,
you know,
being obese is not a good idea,
but if you are clearly looking after yourself and fit,
there's a big range,
which is actually very good news.
Um,
and then finally the weird way in which women really are scrutinized more than
men.
Uh,
700 people were invited to look at these pictures for 250 millisecond.
At 86% of them decided a silvery quickly.
Which one of these one,
two,
three,
or four was the most competent.
The leisurely
we should number
four,
she was seen as being in control and they get together.
Number one got no marks.
But when asked,
which one is the most trustworthy
to whatnot,
so it's treacherous,
right?
Wouldn't you want to be a competent,
trustworthy leader?
I that just remind ourselves,
you know,
men don't have to deal with this and told,
unless you're a TV anchor,
you know,
we're in the business of makeup so women do get scrutinized more.
So,
you know,
that's the day two.
And,
uh,
I,
I'm just going to end with this last slide.
Women and also people of color.
Multicultural folks have little attitudes,
less latitude than the main stream leader type.
You know,
again,
the power of bias,
the power of the existing models of leadership.
So it's very easy to be seen as,
you know,
too provocative to dowdy,
too pushy,
too self depreciating.
The one I love is,
you know,
too young,
too old as one,
very easy to be seen as too inexperienced and not ready,
but also easy to be seen as over the hill.
Right?
There are three years in there when we're just right
men as a whole get 17 years.
So,
you know,
there is,
this gendered thing going on and clearly this does Pete so,
so much into the amazing work that Google is doing on buyers because there is a
need to widen and make more inclusive.
How we see leadership in terms of
how we act,
how we speak and how we look.
But if we're interested in dealing with figuring out how to succeed
this week,
this data's pretty important.
So thank you.
[inaudible]
my question is around the makeup piece.
There's conflicting evidence.
What would you do if you are a woman in terms of what amount of makeup that you
would wear?
You know,
I think it's the kind of well put together saying,
you know,
I kind of good version of you.
You certainly don't want to come out over as you know,
someone quite different.
Uh,
faking some persona is not a good idea,
but it does seem you get for effort that,
you know,
it's good to show that you have put some energy into looking good.
Uh,
it shows respect for yourself,
respect for the team.
Uh,
and perhaps respect for other stakeholders.
Dishevelment uh,
you know,
both men and women you get,
and I think it was a given as part of the example.
You know,
that you've got to look as though you're didn't just fall out of bed,
you know,
the,
uh,
you
put some effort into showing up ready.
Um,
so it was making sound informed decisions,
something that leaders just don't consider
it.
That is a performance,
this is not performance.
This is how you signal.
What do you telegraph in terms of how you act,
speak and look.
Judgment calls.
Incredibly important.
There's another ton of books on that,
right?
This is about,
um,
your image,
but it's about 30% of that basic because it does allow you to be tapped on the
shoulder for some big opportunity you then might screw up,
right?
You don't deliver the right stuff in terms of performance,
in terms of,
you know,
the great judgment calls,
but how would you stand apart from the crowd?
How would you get singled out in the first place?
And,
uh,
given the shot I had a big opportunity.
No,
I'm not trying to say that there aren't some fundamental,
uh,
performance,
you know,
elements that,
uh,
in the end will fuel your journey.
But this is really about the telegraphing of confidence,
the ability to be compelling about what you have to say
and the ability to look the pot enough
so that you don't get knocked off the list.
Because of the fact you've got super near tile.
I don't know what the,
you know,
there's a lot of things that you could no ties a soup on your tee shirt.
Who knows.
There are,
you know,
very culturally specific things.
And if I were to choose my category of,
of what really,
uh,
is,
um,
magical and turbo charging a progression,
it is the communication piece.
Yes.
No,
Yay.
Totally,
totally on.
It needs to be evolved always because you know the demands of the ear or cheek.
Yeah.
You give the example of Sheryl Sandberg and how she shares personal anecdotes
just to relate to people better.
Do you feel that if like women share the personal stories about their families,
they will come across as more emotional?
Yeah.
No,
that's a great story.
You can totally over share and,
um,
it's not a good idea to weigh your family on your sleeve.
Um,
that tends to undermine a,
your edge because there's a lot of bias around working moms.
But I'll tell you a story.
I interviewed someone who is head of the global yeah.
Division that American Express last week.
Uh,
he's African American.
He was wrestling with the challenge of connecting to his global team.
His team is spread around,
I dunno,
countries
and obviously much off his contact is virtual.
He is seen as an enormously,
um,
effective leader.
He is much a love it.
I wanted to know how he did it.
He understands the importance of
okay
being known
to his key
people around the world.
So he goes to,
you know,
every market one supporter and does a town hall.
He also does monthly phone calls so that it's not just email and you know,
uh,
really abstract kind of connection.
So I say,
well,
what do you do at these town halls or what do you do on those calls that make
you so beloved?
I mean,
he's a great before and he does all the other step two but he's seen as someone
you want to go work for.
Okay.
He tells stories for the surface three minutes,
you know,
not a whole bunch of time.
I mean,
there's our business like it needs to get done right.
And these very precious one hour phone calls.
He said,
for instance,
he did a call out of London and the buffer,
uh,
awards,
we're just going on.
He loves.
So he told why he was totally rooting for this and invited folks to get back to
on this movie and you know,
give him some sense of what they love to.
Uh,
and he said,
look,
it's so simple,
but the fact that they knew that,
you know,
I kind of totally screwed up the weekend because I had a seal.
All these movies,
I mean,
mating human,
you know,
in,
in a way that was very,
very important in building trust.
Sometimes a little deeper than that.
For instance,
he grew up in the projects of Oakland
and the first legs of his career were full of struggle.
He'll chat a little piece of that,
not much,
because you don't want to kind of kiss all,
you know,
kiss and tell all kinds of thing that's not gonna work.
You know,
you two need to stay in the business,
a strategic world.
So,
you know,
oftentimes it's not family.
It can be roots,
it can be passions.
But to reveal another dimension of yourself.
Yeah.
Is this empathy thing.
Uh,
and allows,
he said then people read his emails
with a different mindset.
They think they know him.
So you know,
there are things that are quite simple that,
you know,
create a,
an aura of
your ability to lead.
Just a bit of a comment on what you were saying.
I think that the,
the sharing thing,
it shows you as a leader,
but when you're lowish and the organization and you're looking up,
yeah,
sharing is not generally very valuable.
That's a very good,
that's a very wise point.
It actually goes against your job.
But you see,
I think that it's not a to two wells,
uh,
many people in this room both lead small teams and,
our junior in other contexts.
And,
you know,
the,
it's the rare person who doesn't have a sphere of influence.
But you're right,
it is particularly magical coming from someone who's seen it.
So,
um,
I think at Google I feel a lot more comfortable being myself and,
you know,
sharing more than I have elsewhere because there's just turned to Lee.
More respect.
People treat each other really well.
Um,
but I just still have a question about,
you know,
as a woman being able to share things where,
because I've seen these things done very badly.
So is there a bad way to share information about,
you know,
so that you're bringing your whole person to work as opposed to having
completely different personas of work and you know,
your personal life.
One type of sharing,
which is incredibly effective
is how you get feedback.
Right?
Again,
in the data,
we find that a very few high-potential Yancha people get unvarnished feedback.
Uh,
senior folks can't be bothered.
They avoid it because it can be embarrassing to give honest feedback sometimes,
particularly across lines of gender or race.
So it doesn't happen.
It happens between mini me's
again,
you know,
straight Caucasian guys from the right schools do a lot of sharing on the
feedback part,
but oftentimes at a very diverse,
uh,
in a very diverse workplace.
Very little feedback happens and we get a lot of data on this.
So how do you get feedback and how do you give it
and revealing some of your aspirations?
Some of your,
um,
sense of where you see,
uh,
your journey going isn't magical in this regard.
If a younger person says to a supervisor or a mentor or a sponsor or a manager,
I'm giving this presentation next week,
I'm really white hot.
You know,
I think I can nail this,
but there are two areas where I feel I could do some fine tuning.
Can you listen and pay attention and give me feedback?
I mean,
there's ways of presenting this that do not make you vulnerable.
you're saying,
look,
I got it.
I'm excited.
I'm going to do it well,
but please pay attention to this,
that,
or the other seat.
It opens the doors the most amazing day,
useful feedback.
And similarly,
you can do that about,
uh,
you know,
the way you present yourself in other ways and the older person or the most
senior person,
you know,
feels permission to be real.
And of course,
that's how you grow.
Thank you so much.
Amazing conversation.
Enjoyed the questions.
Okay.